On va être à la bourre!
Mais ça va, il est 18h30, c’est un diner, pas un gouter.
Plus vite arrivés, plus vite repartis,
moi je suis claqué, à 22h c’est plié.
T’as pensé à prendre le cadeau?
Oui j’y ai pensé, et j’ai honte d’y avoir pensé.
Parce que ton parfum de vieille y’a aucune chance que ça lui plaise.
Oh la la, c’est typiquement celui que je mets.
Merci hein, merci.
Alors moi, j’ai vachement hésité
et je me suis dit, comme t’as la chance d’avoir un frère artiste,
je parle de moi hein,
je parle pas de Thibault,
parce qu’il est DRH donc c’est pas trop le même …
Je me suis dit le mieux venant de moi,
c’était que je te fasse un petit morceau de uku.
Que j’ai écrit et que j’ai composé moi-même.
Et merde.
Ca-Caroline,
c’est ton anniversaire.
Et je t’aime, moi ton frère.
Voilà, après j’ai pas la suite
parce que j’ai pas d’autres rimes en "ère".
Ben "calvaire".
De quoi?
Bon ben je vais chercher le gâteau moi.
Mais ça va rho.
Moi j’ai bossé toute la journée, alors j’ai la tête …
On dirait mon père.
Non mais, qu’est-ce qu’elle a?
Ben en fait, chaque année qui passe,
elle vieillit d’un an.
Et ça, ça la …
Ca craint.
Ah ben t’es là?
Ah non mais va te rassoir, j’allais rapporter le gâteau.
T’es sûre que ça va?
Bof bof.
Je me sens vieille.
Très très vieille.
Fatigué?
Ouais.
J’ai fait la teuf toute la nuit.
Un mardi?
Tu sais, c’est normal de se sentir vieille.
Et ça arrive à plus de gens que tu ne crois.
Arrête, arrête, toi tu fais encore hyper jeune dans ta tête.
Mais si, c’est vrai,
moi j’arrive pas à faire abstraction comme toi.
Parce que tout, tout me rappelle que je suis vieille.
Je paye les transports plein pot,
je paye le ciné plein pot,
les chansons que j’aime bien passent sur CherieFM,
mon mec me baise qu’en missionnaire …
J’ai saisi l’idée. Tu sais,
on se connait pas si bien que ça toi et moi
donc les détails…
Je suis sûre que vous vous baisez dans plein de positions.
Ben moi au bout d’un moment, j’ai passé l’âge pour certains trucs.
J’ai 35 ans maintenant,
je peux plus là, faire des concerts toute la nuit, tout ça.
Attends, regarde mec, moi j’ai 33.
Ben justement deux ans, c’est quand même …
C'est ...
Si.
Même vous, vous m’offrez de l’eau de Cologne qui pue.
Enfin, sans vouloir te vexer.
Oh, non, t’inquiètes, je trouve que ça pue aussi.
Et dis-toi, j’ai 28 ans,
et bien j’ai jamais fumé de la drogue de ma vie, jamais.
Oui ben ça à la limite…
Oh non non non. Oh non je peux pas.
Ouh, c’est prêt!
Alors, Caroline, ton frère à la limite
il m’en faut plus pour être surpris
mais toi, un peu de tenue quand même.
Mais je m’en bats la chatte
de ta tenue, ok?
C’est mon anniversaire,
tu peux me laisser kiffer un peu s’il te plait?
Voilà, ok, je fais ce que je veux.
Si j’ai envie de manger sans couverts, je mange sans couverts.
J’ai 28 ans alors je fais ce que je veux.
Regarde, je peux même manger sans les mains.
Mais attends, qu’est-ce qui vous arrive là? Sérieux?
Ben figure toi que je suis foncedef.
C’est Lorelei qui m’a fait fumé de la teuch.
Non alors deux lattes, vraiment pas plus.
N’empêche que j’ai même pas crapoté
alors maintenant vous arrêtez de faire ces gueules.
Et on fête tranquillement mon anniversaire.
Parce que regardez Thomas, il a peut-être l’air attardé
mais au moins lui il s’éclate.
Merci!
Tiens d’ailleurs, ressors ton ukulélé là.
Non, ça c’est peut-être pas obligé.
Les filles, vous êtes ridicules.
On dirait des gamines.
Alors ok, j’ai compris,
alors ici c’est l’équipe des supers méga nazes.
Et moi je propose qu’on fasse l’équipe des supers nanas.
Oh yes, je peux faire Rebelle?
Oui!
Oh yes!
Mais par contre maintenant, tu te tais.